okay get ready for my ultimate guide to
bacon whether it's breads cakes tarts
pies or pastries bacon is one of the
most seductive skills in the kitchen it
fills the house with fantastic aromas
and put irresistible food on the table
now I'm gonna put you on the road to
bacon nirvana starting with an easy
bread packed with big gutsy flavors
Olive tomato and rosemary focaccia
I absolutely love baking bread there's
something really satisfying about doing
it and this for catcher recipe is very
hands-on but the end result is something
really really tasty first off start with
the dough tip 500 grams of strong bread
flour into a mixing bowl and add 20
grams of semolina that gives the [ __ ]
out sure it's sort of rustic charm now
there's one thing for cash your needs
it's really good seasonings you can't
seasoned bread Alfa's basis that are
going right the road begin sprinkling 15
grams of dried yeast take some warm
water and 50 mils of olive oil top of
that water that gives it its really nice
silky rich texture make a little well
mix up that yeast water and oil then
start off with the fingers keep your
fingers nice and oppressed like a little
sort of whisk going in there I'm looking
for a really nice sort of relaxed
well let's just start to come together
touch more water with oil in there
give a little swirl and then again the
secret is to sort of knead it gently
don't overwork it it's a sort of easy
bread to make a nice one to start off
with when you're making bread for the
first time basically needing means just
knit it together
just hanging lightly flour your board
and let's just need that for catcher
into a nice smooth dough I'm sure you
don't over add too much flour otherwise
it's sort of dries out the dough
something quite magical about making
bread you can switch off and lose
yourself my first job for a
three-michelin-star establishment was a
baker I was 22 years of age and as I
start at midnight I was under such a
tight schedule
one o'clock my bread then two o'clock
brown bread three o'clock Souder
four o'clock cheese bread and five
o'clock proof baked six o'clock crack
them open and taste it was amazing
beautiful look stunning hasn't risen yet
lead your dough to rise in a warm place
till it's double in size
we call this proving
[Music]
that beautiful lot of chefs sort of need
it for the second time but I'm looking
for really nice light airy eighties for
catcher take your tray touch it olive
oil in there season it at the bottom
really important that's the exciting
thing about a focaccia you've got a
really nice sort of salty top and salty
bottom and just with a touch of olive
oil on your hands gently push that in an
almost massage it into the corners it's
possible to put sort of olives and
tomatoes and garlic through the dough
but it never really allows the dough to
sort of aerate properly when you put so
much ingredients in I'm gonna stick
around on top use your finger and so
I'll just push them in salt on top some
pepper on top as well and once a nice
fresh amazing rosemary just hold the
stalk and just pull off and then just
sprinkle down generous in the rosemary
really important to have that nice
fragrance on top of the focaccia finish
it off before goes in the little drizzle
of olive oil so it almost sings in those
little pockets of flavor Olive tomato
rose me and olive oil in to the oven
bake your focaccia at 200 degrees for 30
to 35 minutes smells delicious
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
you can hear how crispy that is you
can't beat a nice warm fresh slice of
home cooked piccata
it's rustic charming and it's the
perfect way to start baking making
homemade focaccia is so addictive
getting to grips with bacon is just a
matter of confidence and once you grasp
the basics then the possibilities are
limitless here are three more of my
favorite super simple bread recipes to
get you going
kicking off with my simple soda bread
first up measure out your dry
ingredients plain flour wholemeal flour
salt castor sugar
and bicarbonate of soda mix get 450 min
of buttermilk or most of it in and
combined buttermilk has a wonderful
subtle sour note that gives this bread a
deliciously different taste you can get
it in most other big supermarkets if
your dough is a bit stiff add the rest
of your buttermilk flour your board
gently knead the mixture for about 30
seconds until it's all combined dust
your baking tray place your dough in the
center and score a deep crust with a
knife to get a perfect crust then simply
bake in a preheated oven for 30 to 35
minutes amazingly easy absolutely
delicious and foolproof hot crusty
homemade soda bread whenever you want my
next no sweat bread recipe is even
faster to make quick flat breads with
lemon thyme and ricotta
for the dough mix first slice a leek
lengthwise and chopped and sowed in a
pan with olive oil and butter till
tender season next combine flour with a
pinch of seasoning and olive oil and
mixing your cooked leeks bring the dough
together in a bowl with a drop of warm
water cover and rest for 20 minutes
allow the dough mixture to relax means
the resulting bread will be nice and
soft then dust the dough with flour
mold into a sausage shape slice it into
rounds
[Music]
and flatten with a rolling pin
then simply fry in a hot dry pan
[Music]
when golden and crisp on each side
removed for simple supper served with a
cottage cheese lemon zest and fresh
thyme so simple so fast and so versatile
flatbreads to die for next how to make
one of the world's most popular bread
based foods fast mozzarella and rosemary
pizza
[Music]
for the pizza dough
ad DS to warm water put a tablespoon of
sugar and lead to one side in a separate
bowl add sieve flour make it well and
add your olive oil and yeast mixture get
your hands right in to bring it together
then knead for about 10 minutes on a
floured surface until even and smooth
put back into the bowl cover and leave
in a warm place to prove once is roughly
doubled in size knock any excess air out
place back on your surface divide your
dough into four balls and simply flatten
an olive oil to a hot pan and put in the
pizza dough
Pizza is usually cooked in a searingly
hot oven but this pan cook method works
brilliantly
as the dough starts to bubble and the
bass turns golden spoon over tomato
passata which is sip tomatoes
and tearing chunks of mozzarella then
simply transfer to a hot grill until
golden and bubbly finish with fresh
rosemary I love this classic combination
but you can easily adapt it and add your
own favorite topping for a perfect pizza
in minutes so simple so fast so
irresistible three recipes they'll
change the way you think about homemade
bread forever
beautiful
whether I'm doing a simple sponge cake
or making an elaborate tart I want my
baking to be the best it can be
so I always start with the best
ingredients I can find knowledge is
crucial the more you know personally
about where your ingredients are from
and how they produce the better
[Applause]
[Music]
flower to get the lowdown on one of the
key ingredients to brilliant baking they
always pays to ask an expert and if is
what manner can really rise to the
occasion it's professional Miller mark
Abel doing a job like this means that
you end up thinking and living a flower
if that's obsession I'm sister Ally's
mill which is stood in Norfolk since
1835 mark uses traditional stones to
grind his flour so it really knows his
stuff what actually comes off the field
something like this still husked still
needs to be processed before we can
actually mill it
we're then cutting down to something
like this which is ready to be milled
all this is a great big machine which
means you don't have to do it by hand
rather than try and improve its
performance by adding additional
chemicals what we're trying to do is
mill it in the best way to get that
performance from it if you can put a
seed in between stones you can make
flour out of it it's that simple
barley was what was traditionally used
to make bread for people to live off
ODEs can be used as well and of course
good old spelt the great grandmother of
modern wheats which has the most
fantastic flavor and is because of its
primitive nature the proteins in it
simpler so a lot of people could eat
that they can't eat modern weight keep
your eyes on the shelves look and see
what is there and if something
structures being potentially interesting
then get it and try it mix your own
blend your own together so that you can
get the flavor that you want with the
performance that you want Mars right
different flours performin taste wildly
different and so they're well worth
trying out here's my quick guide to some
of the flowers I like using strong flour
is one to choose for standard bread
making the high the protein content the
crust of your loaf will be
the flower hailing from Italy double
zero it's super finely milled and
perfect for pasta I like to use for
pizzas too because it produces a nice
crispy crust like the one on my
mozzarella and rosemary version rye
flour will give you really dense fruity
flavored bread fruit cakes or scones if
it's too heavy for you just mix it with
standard wheat flour and when you are
baking remember the self raising flour
is just plain flour with raisin Asian's
added so if you run out you can add
baking powder and salt to your plain
flour and get baking
[Music]
that's the real stuff that's it fresh
flour straight out the mill is so
superior in flavor and performance that
is only when you come to use it you
realize what the difference is if you're
going to experiment with ingredients in
baking
you still need to follow some basic
rules to make sure things turn out
brilliantly every time
then whether you're a master baker we
were just starting out you can pimp up
the classics whether it's a Victoria
sponge or a fruits gone and that's the
lesson perfectly illustrated by my next
recipe sponge with fresh ginger baking
is part chemistry part imagination but
you've got to rely on the rules for
great results so anytime you'll see me
reaching for the scales
first off eggs sugar butter and when I
say way out of the ingredients it does
literally mean way out to the final gram
175 now 175 grams of sugar that's 350
grams in total cream the butter and the
sugar
to get a delicious light sponge start
carefully on slow speed only speed up as
the butter and sugar really start to
cream together keep that already nice to
light and see how it's changed color so
important to beginning eggs in the
minute whisk adding one egg at a time
stops the mix from separating the second
oh yeah
[Music]
that's what we're looking for a really
nice sort of light airy ad texture now a
flavour the sponge no teaspoon of
vanilla extract
like perfumes the mix one teaspoon of
baking powder
that gives lightness 175 grams of flour
and we have a civet a to get rid of any
lumps and B to keep it really nice and
fine 175 what I'm gonna beat that out
we're just gonna lightly fold that in
now what I'm looking for is a really
nice and loose dough that's looking a
little bit too firm so just a little
splash of milk a couple of tablespoons
that relaxes the mixture down helps
create that nice almost dropping
consistency sort of wander yeah starting
to drop take a non sticky loose bottom
caked in greasy with butter then coated
with flour to avoid the sponge sticking
just give that a little shake
now just get the back of the spatula
make sure you got no Peaks on my sponge
to make sure the sponge base nice and
evenly
tap the tin a few times to knock out any
air pockets that might have formed in
the mixture now into the oven bake for
30 to 35 minutes at 180 degrees as
that's cooking prepare the ginger cream
for the center 300 mil of cream give
that nice whisk whisking cream by hand
gives you so much more control and it's
so easy to over whip cream on that nice
light ginger cream in the center I don't
it grainy nothing worse when cream
starts to separate now let's get into
that 3/4 stage little stiff peaks I'll
stop that for 2 minutes fresh ginger now
got a really nice large slice of ginger
it smells incredible it's so fragrant
Ginger's like sort of peeling a potato
just take it all those little dark spots
now get your grater getting that grater
you can chop the ginger really finely
I've gone almost like a puree of ginger
going through but the juice as well take
your knife just spread out
Tosun scrotum
it's fragrant it's not sweet it's got a
really nice taste set that in the fridge
[Music]
smells incredible the night around the
outside dude sure the cake doesn't stick
to the Tim before turning it out yeah
get your hands under shop and battle
while your cake cools only like a really
nice sweet chocolate coating pour 300
mils of double cream into a saucepan add
two tablespoons of golden syrup to make
the top nice and glossy
then whisk chop this up really thinly so
as it melts quickly 50 grams of butter
that's gonna give the chocolate a really
nice shine all your cream mix it in give
that a really good stir there's a
chocolate the butter melts it thickens
like a shiny that is so nice to finish
it with something sweet on top topping
done time to build your sponge cake look
at the halfway mark there and just
gently slice and really take your time
all the way through lift
mmm delicious a nice big dollop in the
middle gonna be stingy
let me type with a cream another dollop
and top spread that very carefully lift
the lid and just sit that on top that's
why I start off with a little extra
cream in there so I'll squash you down
clean you just push it out to the side
I'm not finished
poor the luxurious chocolate topping
over the sponge be generous and make
sure the cake is coated thoroughly diva
a gorgeous finish at the bottom the
ladle and spread whoa one more wha
there know when to say stop and
something looks bad delicious I swipe
dive in there
[Music]
next five more my 100 tips to help you
cook better and of course these are all
about baking kicking off with how to
whip cream whipping cream now the
important part here is whipping the
cream to a 3/4 stage if we over whip it
it will split so be very careful double
cream in now when we wish things we
whisk it in the shape of a figure of 8
and if you spin the ball as you whip the
cream you get to release it from the
bottom so whips evenly whisk whisk whisk
and it should just sit inside the whisk
and start to sort of fall out just
perfect
3/4 stage double cream done room
temperature cream whips much faster than
cold so you'll need to take your cream
out of the fridge 30 minutes before you
want to whip it unless of course you
want to work on your biceps a great tip
Trent milk and cream from boiling over
in a saucepan is to simply lay a wooden
spoon across the top the cream bubbles
will rise up and hit the wooden handle
and then fall back into the pan instead
of bubbling over
sticky stuff like treacle and gone syrup
can be a real mess to measure out my tip
is to rub the spoon with a neutral oil
like rapeseed and any sticky ingredients
will slide straight off and my tip for
greasing cake tins is to keep on butter
wrappers on hand and use them to crease
when needed follow my ultimate cookery
course packed with key lessons and top
tips and 100 recipes to stake your life
on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking